the trouble is that some questions are
disingenuous that students are asking
them to try and catch teachers out or to
try and poke at them or rebel against
the system and then as a result teachers
may feel that they're being undermined
and then they can't give a genous answer
to the question or to say that the
question is a bad question whereas
actually what we should do is to create
an environment in which it's fine if a
teacher can't answer a question because
then that's a great question then what
we can do is we can all sit down and
learn how to figure out the answer to a
question using the resources around us
so then hopefully the disingenuous
questions will go away because there
will be no social cache left to being
able to ask a question a teacher can't
answer so then students will only ask
things that they generally want to know